aoc had a pretty wild line i have to get
to it before the mailbag aoc
is out defending planned parenthood for
saving lives she begins she says
conservatives i don't want to hear about
planned parenthood
when you support the death penalty first
and foremost
i don't want to hear a single person on
this committee or outside of this
committee
talk about what about uh
valuing life when they continue to
uphold the death penalty
when they continue to support policies
that disproportionately incarcerate
and lead to the deaths of black men and
people throughout this country
and uphold in a in absolutely
unjust medical system that exists for
profit that allows people to die because
they can't afford to live
put a pause right there i don't have a
lot of time so we'll do this quickly
executing convicted criminals is
different than murdering innocent babies
the u.s justice system over it
intentionally incarcerates criminals
that's what they go for
if if some groups commit crime at higher
rates
that ain't the cops fault that ain't the
system's fault uh
it's a problem but it ain't the cops
problem and third
the united states has the best health
care in the world that's why people from
other countries that allegedly have
better health care when they want good
health care they come to the united
states and then she goes on and makes
her
her real point in addition to that if we
want to talk about planned parenthood
let's talk about how many lives planned
parenthood
has saved and how many babies have been
born because of the prenatal care
provided by planned parenthood
and if you don't if you don't believe it
and if you've never met a planned
parenthood baby
i'm happy to let you know that i am one
and that my mother received and relied
on prenatal care
from planned parenthood when she was
pregnant with me
and so if we're concerned about life we
don't get to talk
about anyone else who's not concerned
about the full spectrum of that
when we are upholding policies that kill
people
so that's obviously preposterous the
argument she's making if aoc really
if her mother did go to planned
parenthood at various times i i and i
have no reason to believe that because
aoc lies all the time but if that's true
if aoc
slipped through the cracks of the
abortionist ghouls
at planned parenthood that's good good
for her that's a that's a good story
the fact is that planned parenthood
kills hundreds of thousands of babies a
year
their business is abortion if
accidentally some woman walks in and
they don't they're not able to get their
fangs into them
and and convince them to kill their
babies that is a happy
accident that happens at planned
parenthood but the argument she's making
here is if you
don't oppose the death penalty you can't
you can't
oppose abortion not true if you don't
support socialist medicine you can't
oppose abortion
not true you can you really can you
don't need to fall for the traps that
the left is laying before you
even when that involves candidates on
our own side
that are that are i think tricking us
wittingly or unwillingly into
into accepting a lot of very dangerous
leftist premises
oh hello there oh i barely noticed you
came in
you might not notice that i come in to
your computer if you don't ring that
bell
if you don't like and you subscribe
because then you won't get the
notifications youtube already
doesn't want you to see the videos that
we put out so make sure you ring the
bell right now
we'll see you next time